if you're an executive and entrepreneur
businessman who travels a lot today I
want to share with you some tips on how
to be an efficient traveler I'm Patrick
dataview host of value taming weekly and
today literally right after this video
I'm about to jump on an international
flight then I'm going to Fort Lauderdale
Chicago then I'd come back to LA and all
these years I used to be an amateur a
traveler ways to be frustrated watching
other people go through it swiftly and I
was always figuring out a way and it
would take a long time so eventually
after 15 years of experience I've come
together with things that work to become
an efficient travel and hopefully you
can take advantage of some of these tips
for yourself as well okay few items very
basic to keep in mind one business cards
how often have you gone on a business
trip and you forgot your business cards
always have a stack in your bag to your
piece you have a forgotten yori piece
before how many times have we forgotten
this puppy before right I have multiple
of these in my briefcase in my car at
the office in my home everywhere because
I know we missed these a lot phone
chargers have extra phone chargers
everywhere for you to not run out of
batteries on your phone because how many
of us have been on a trip and we had our
phone run out of batteries next portable
phone charger this is a required thing
to have as an entrepreneur in your bag
next hand sanitiser when you sit on the
plane sanitize your hands nowadays they
have them at a lot of airports but if
they don't you got to bring your own as
well sanitize your hands sanitize the
table that you're going to put your
hands on and the side where you put your
armrest here sanitize that as well
because a lot of times someone's sick
they sneeze they touch that you touch
your face you get a cold as an
entrepreneur you can't afford to do that
because one we could set you back a lot
of momentum you're creating in your
business next all the apps of airlines
you fly on have them on your phone so if
it's American Airlines Delta Southwest
have it on your phone if there's delays
whatever it may be they send it to you
and they tell you if you had a delay all
of that stuff will go on your phone so
you don't have delays taking place for
you next have you ever gone on a line to
check in a need a security checkpoint
and you have to take off your shoes you
have to take off your belt you have to
take off your app or your computer
you're left have you ever
done that before and you just sit down
you're wondering why are these folks on
this side they go to the place that says
TSA pre they go through the whole thing
and you're on line for 45 minutes
they must be pilots they must be flight
attendants they must be CIA or there
must be FBI because they get to go
through quickly well they came out with
a system a few years ago that you
yourself can be part of TSA pre as well
it's called the Global Entry Program if
you look at the screen here it's by US
Customs and Border Protection and so
what they do is you pay them it's about
a hundred dollars if you're an American
Express user that hundred dollars
American Express will refund you but if
you're not you pay $100 and that hundred
dollars they go through doing a
background check on you misdemeanor
felony things they check on you if you
come out clear if you come out clear you
don't need to take off your belt you
don't need to take out your computer you
don't need to take off your shoes and
you don't get to stay in the same line
as everybody else you go into TSA pre
line with the airlines that are approved
you don't wait in line for anybody you
simply go in and if you are TSA pre the
other benefits you get is you get bumped
up into first-class you get bumped up
into business class airlines like having
people who are TSA pre because they want
to feel safe you're going to make them
feel safe you're going to get a lot of
perks for it take advantage of it's only
$100 do it before everybody else starts
doing it another thing is with getting
there early you have you ever had on a
trip where you going and you all of a
sudden you miss your check-in time and
day six within 45 minutes you can check
in your bag you're upset because they
say you need to wait for the next flight
five hours and you're going to miss this
appointment you were supposed to make
and you don't know how to make up or you
just purely frustrate it here's here's
one way that works and you can do it
every time so they are not allowing you
get on the flight because the check-in
for the baggage too late but not you
you can get your ticket for yourself
even off your weight you get the ticket
you check your bagging on a next flight
even if it's five hours later you get on
your flight you make your meeting five
hours later your bag will land in the
city that you're going to you can simply
send somebody to go pick up your bag and
bring it to you happened to be on a trip
to New Mexico is being interviewed on
NBC
same exact thing happened
got on my flight went through my back
showed up six hours later we were squirt
away I made it on my TV show that was
supposed to be and everybody went home
happy so that's something to keep in
mind if you are going to be late another
point is this if you go into business
meeting with an agenda have your
assistant or staff print out an agenda
with as much details on it as possible
who you're meeting with information
about the meeting you're having with the
person what's the outcome of it what are
they wanting what do we want who are you
going to meet at this time who are you
going to go have to meet at this place
the details name of the person all those
details you're going to have the more
info they give you the better it is
next thing when I travel on my phone I
have in one of my notes section that
writes out exactly the restaurants have
been all the cities all over the world I
go I have a place in my notes section
that tells me in this city I go to these
three restaurants this restaurant I
order sushi at this restaurant I order
Italian at this restaurant I ordered
this and then it tells me what things
I've ordered before that I like the most
food I have it in my phone couple
reasons why you need him when you go
back it's tough to find good restaurants
the other thing is when you know a
friend that's going to a certain City
can always recommend a good restaurant
to them next Southwest Airlines if
you're flying on Southwest Airlines and
you want to get an aisle seat or you
want to get an exit seat I will see it
there's a B C because you know how you
check-in with Southwest if you're before
B 30 you'll normally get an aisle seat
after B 30 it's tough to get an aisle
seat if you want an exit seat you got to
be before a 30 generally if you're below
a 38 25 you'll get yourself an exit seat
if you want an exit seat with Southwest
Airlines another thing is with American
Express lounge you have these airports
lines if you have a delay on your flight
or any of that stuff an American Express
Platinum card allows you to go into the
lounges that they have at different
airports as well as a few different
cards the diner card the Centurion card
if you're a you know Platinum flyer
member with any of these Airlines you
have some advantages to go to these
lounges they have chargers there they
have TVs there they have bars there they
have restaurants there it's quiet you're
sitting with other business people as
well when you go there another point
here when I'm traveling I don't use taxi
I useful barber is a great app to pick
up download use they're very effective
they're very efficient they're very
fast you get a lot of discounts it's a
good system to use when you land when
you land
write a note give it to the pilots say
thank you for safe landing put your
business card in ER you'd be surprised
how many times our pilot that sees you
on another flight will greet you and
sometimes there's additional perks that
comes with it another thing when you go
to an airport and you go to sky cap
you know the sky cap is a curbside a
system where they take your bats and
they check in instead of going inside
and waiting 15 minutes when you do that
know that they work for tips always have
cash with you to tip them $1.00 per bag
if they don't have to take you to the
front if they have to take you to the
front it's $2 per bag you're given three
bags at six bucks to give them five bags
it's ten bucks
just keep that rule one dollar if you're
not they're not taking it in two dollars
if they are taking it in with the bags
and last but not least I am NOT a fan of
Wi-Fi on planes I know a lot of people
do a lot of business on planes with
Wi-Fi I'm not I think
flights are great opportunities as an
entrepreneur and a businessman to have a
therapeutic moment of just taking a
break from the world and we need that as
entrepreneurs my suggestion
read write letters reflect that's what I
do on my flights it gives me a break
from the world I love to read I love to
write I love to write letters I'll have
to sit down and reflect about life and
just take notes about what's been
happening with life on how I can improve
and I can do this and I can do that
great time to do it that's typically as
an entrepreneur businessman that's one
in a million miles an hour
you need your break flights or those
breaks for you take advantage of it
don't waste your money on Wi-Fi you'll
be more thankful you didn't when you
land because you're in a better state
better place
it's my message of the week - I'm please
be sure to share this video with other
people who are also travelers and
subscribe to this channel thanks for
watching today I want to share with you
some specific tips sounded like Mike
Tyson for a second let me share with you
some tips I travel Customs and Border
Protection
I'm Patrick bid